you know i always wonder is it like
really the world is getting soft or were
there always really soft people this
whole time but you just didn't hear
about it all the time or is it the world
getting too brand new
there you go
i don't know i don't know what it is but
i asked myself something i'm like really
i like i understand i've had people
think you know i think but [ __ ]
you open the hatch and just jump out
like that's super [ __ ] dangerous
think about it
think about it think about it
everything the point about this world is
getting things to be done easy
like
it's easier to
to to communicate with people it's
easier to cook it's easier to everything
is to improve how things are done so of
course we're gonna have less and less
hardships are
the things that are hard are going to be
less and less it's not going to be the
same thing so
yeah at some point we're going to be
solved because it's not going to be the
same thing there's a few hundred years
back [ __ ] had to do their own
butter have you ever turned butter
[ __ ]
in that thing you have to [ __ ] turn
that's long i don't like butter so just
to spread butter or to have butter for
your toast or anything like that it
takes you
three days
now
two seconds i could buy that [ __ ] so
yeah everybody's everybody's like
do you think someone that turns butter
for three days to make it kick is gonna
have a panic attack
no man they got other [ __ ] to worry
about but we don't have [ __ ] to worry
really about
so so i just remember when there was a
time where like getting called [ __ ] was
terrifying
yeah and then after that you know the
people was like yeah you are what you
eat rather be a [ __ ] than a dick
and i was just like
i'm just in tune with my emotions it's
like [ __ ] people just own it
they just own everybody on it
they own it yeah i'm not saying no but
you know that's pretty much the general
thing but i do understand that panic
attacks do happen it's not something
that people can control people that have
panic attacks don't want to have panic
attacks
they don't want that [ __ ] yeah but they
can't help it you know i mean but if i'm
just being my selfish me i'm like man i
got places to go so can you just not die
today
just like whenever you take the metro
and someone just wants to commit suicide
like bruh uh
i'm already late so if you could wait
like
i thought
if you could wait like 15 minutes
people are selfish like that because i
gotta go places
after me hey um
you best believe [ __ ] just see
somebody jumped up
can somebody clean this nigga's brains
off so we get up with this [ __ ] i got
sex to go to exactly
somebody please go clean his brains i'll
go get some brains
let's move
were you the metro man it's a different
ballgame like you're already on the
poverty train so [ __ ] making
your life harder is annoying it's just
like bruh me out of all the people you
have to [ __ ] with me yeah i'm the poor
dude i'm already poor i'm not the one
that [ __ ] up your life we got bridges
[ __ ] just jump off
i'll just jump off why are you making
everybody notice god damn like don't
kill yourself what if you're going to do
it jump off the bridge you see you see
what we meant when we said that you know
comedy ruined us
obviously we'll make it obvious comedy
that's just poverty
made me like hate wasting my time i
already got to take this shitty [ __ ]
train like let's get this [ __ ] moving i
have a joke about that it's like it's
like when i'm on the bus and then a
wheelchair wants to get out i'm like
leave this man
i love that joke
hey i'm looking at the bus store like
hey [ __ ] i'll slip you some money they
can just burn
warm speed
we'll say we never saw
[Music]
oh my god and guess what hey guess what
this [ __ ] gets off three stops later
you could have rolled
into the incline [ __ ]
so you got to watch that whole [ __ ]
again in reverse
bro that's the poverty of me talking
like
die bro i'll be getting mad here's the
funny thing ah if the bus doesn't stop
for me [ __ ] them
you'll [ __ ] the whole public transport
system you saw me run again you left
but if the bus talks to other people i'm
like [ __ ] hurry up that's what i'm
saying
that's what i'm saying it's
people being me it's like whatever my
friends that are that are that are
driving they're like [ __ ] these [ __ ]
pedestrians and then when they get to
walking up she's like yo yo chill i'm
walking
they switch it's all about them it's not
about the situation i agree
what do we have next there's nothing
worse than like working a minimum wage
job taking the bus and then the [ __ ]
bus drives past you yes
yes
yes i've been there been there done that
got the t-shirt i can't accept it if i'm
late
[ __ ] if you early oh yeah i'm gonna
lose my [ __ ] money
oh my god i look at the schedule i'm
gonna get there like three four minutes
early and i'm looking the bus stop is
right there because there's no one at
the bus stop this [ __ ] just
rolls by you gotta wait 40 minutes yeah
yeah
that's some south shore [ __ ]
nah bro that that yeah but i guess we
triggered the [ __ ] out of you that's not
a comedian thing that's a poverty that's
a poverty thing that's awesome i am mad
at you but you're right yeah that that
felt that [ __ ] that's possible when if
you're late you're late but if you're
early and you pass
yeah
i've had it where the bus is late and
because the bus is late
they want to meet their whatever quota
they have to do with time so they just
rip past you yeah
yeah that's infuriating yeah
i'm already late so whoops but i
understand him if he was already
late you mean you're at the bus stop and
he
yeah that's just waiting he's supposed
to come at 11 10 yeah 11 15 this guy
goes [ __ ] i got to get to the terminus
yeah 11 20. yeah
yeah
yeah i think i've
punched bus shelters before oh
absolutely
yeah i've i've made a gavin of myself
and punch a few a few things yes
it's only gavin's that push
a bunch of walls in in the in the
bedroom
what else we got